[Music]
when we want to like present our home
for other people to make
a purchase what do you usually do to the
home i don't think
i've never sold my own home before but
then i guess the only people here that's
actually sold the house
is these two huge guys i'm talking
specifically to you guys i actually
bought and sold a house before i even
lived in one but joe's the only one
answering oh true
that's tradition that's tradition
i have zero knowledge so let me tell you
growing up as a girl i'll tell you what
my
experience is well i don't have
experience
but listen up yeah yeah sorry i think
out loud
because he's like literally turning his
whole body to like block his job
and then joe turns him around let me
tell you
well all right joe no but this is like a
you know i think common sense gesture
right when you when you uh sell a home
or sell the car you sell anything you
want to make it nice you want to clean
it up you want to
refurbish whatever yeah you want to you
know do some
so that's what you just did right make
it appealing yeah so we hired a staging
company
and they come in and they kind of assess
the house so you don't want it to look
too personal like you want the house to
look like
um they they want you want them to be
able to envision their lives in it
so we have to take down all of our
family photos friends photos personal
photos
we have to take all of tyka's toys put
it in his room
so you kind of have to make it a little
bit more bland aaron
airbnb looking so that people can walk
in and go oh i can see my life here
yes so that that would be the typical
way to sell a house
and uh for someone in kentucky
they listed a house for 375 thousand
dollars
a mansion over there right it's five
acres
that's pretty big that's uh well it's
actually only three bedrooms but then
there's
four bathrooms um six garages
uh yeah there's more bathrooms than
bedrooms yes i found that
that kind of weird yeah and they they
also posted a
a a 3d tour of it so they they actually
went
out of the way to do a 3d i like how
we're all impressed walk through just
because you said it's in kentucky
dude because if you say 300 000 kentucky
i'm picturing wayne manor bro well it's
not quite wayman right
300 000 in kentucky sounds like a
compound not even a mansion
yeah it's it's pretty it's like a 300
acre yeah yes pablo escobar con 360.
llamas and going back to what bart was
saying you know when you sell a house
you want to try and envision your life
there right
let's see if you guys can envision your
life
here this is this is a 3d wall
come on you [ __ ] paint how they
posted their own
oh my god why do they
[ __ ] no do they sell stuff on ebay
i don't know do they cut cocaine in
their kitchen
i have no idea look at this didn't even
wash their [ __ ] dishes
what oh it's like american flag this
looks like the sun's at anarchy [ __ ]
headquarters or something it does
even it does it looks like an operation
of some sort yeah yeah this is
a shop yeah see they have an ebay
business look at that [ __ ] that's a big
house though yeah
is that a [ __ ] bathtub that you walk
in and you walk out clean yeah it's like
a car wash
you like that part huh yeah it seems so
narrow yeah that's pretty cool dude i
couldn't live here holy [ __ ] you could
live here
what the [ __ ] i can't envision and it's
a library he's got a library
this place is nuts dude the whole bottom
floor is a store
i just can't figure out if it's a
bedroom or a garage or a kitchen like
what am i in
this is the biggest floor that's all you
need to know that's a lot this looks
like my san diego
house i grew up in honestly really oh
cause your parents your mom's a hoarder
right
you know what it looks like an amazon
fulfillment center it does did you say
it's so
organized it's more organized than a
hoarder's house yeah that is not
organized listen
that says a lot about how you guys no no
no have you seen a hoarder's house
[ __ ] yeah it's still having space to
move around
that's organized for a floor yeah you
can see the
well pretty good go crazy because i
lived in a hoarder's house
and we do have aisles for walking and
hoarder houses just so you know
so it was organized it was an
organization you could argue it's
organized but
uh it's just to walk away really you see
it's not organized walkways
if you don't have a walkway is that not
a hoarder's house
okay to him compared to a hoarder's
house you guys got to watch
the [ __ ] extreme addiction you have
to climb up a [ __ ] diaper bar
version though yeah true so you're
you're
you're a mild hoarder well no my parents
my parents were my mom is a hoarder for
sure
but we all kind of fought back as we
lived there i see yeah
so you that that was the meeting in the
middle yeah yeah what does that mean
when you fight back against a horse so
you can actually
start the secret clean up things yeah
okay guys by looking them in the eye and
she unsells it somehow she brings it
right back
it's like the mask like you throw out
the window and flies back yes
and they accuse you of throwing things
away that you didn't throw away because
they lost them no
and they cry while they're doing it oh
my god oh my god
one time my dad caught wind that because
they went on a trip together
and i was like i'm getting u-haul and
i'm gonna [ __ ] clean this whole place
up i was gonna hire a bunch of day
workers and we're gonna [ __ ] take
care of this [ __ ]
and my dad caught wind of it because my
brother [ __ ] leaked it to my dad what
else
he called me and [ __ ] chewed me out
for like 30 minutes about
how i'm gonna hurt my mother can't
believe your brother's a rat he's a
[ __ ] rat dude yeah what an arc
that's all i got for that don't trust
his brother
all right so this house uh it's okay
three bedrooms four bathroom lift
listed for 375 000 dollars in louisville
oh
where the baseball bats come from yeah
they build baseball bats yeah does it
say square footage the sluggers
it doesn't say square footage here uh
yeah i'm actually really you're leaving
us
yeah we're going to continue that yeah i
mean you guys are going to vegas
but it ain't kentucky kentucky well
kentucky seems kind of nice and you know
what honestly got fried chicken over
there with all the stuff that's inside
this house
i'm sure you could actually sell uh a
lot of the [ __ ] inside the house and
make your money back from buying the
house
no that's not coming with the [ __ ]
because with the stuff in it i don't
know
no they that's treasure for them they'll
never give you their treasure let me
tell you that let me tell you the back
story of this house all right so
uh let me just kind of go through a list
of things all right the home looks like
an
ordinary residence from the outside but
this 3d walkthrough reveals
all this [ __ ] that's inside the
house previously
previously served as a church what i
don't like it as a school
wow and a daycare center so it's huge
creepy
records and features separate male and
female bathrooms i think we saw the male
one uh the
oh and that's why that jacuzzi that was
a baptizing place yes
it's a baptizing so you walk in and you
walk out yep here
yes so every time you take a shower
you're blessed by the lord himself and
what's even more strange is that right
outside of that uh baptism
bath thing there's a stash of porno dvds
there's uh they didn't even move out for
the picture
or the tour no the porno dvd i i have
photos of them they just said [ __ ] it
fashion dolls old christmas decorations
oh it might be things that they're
selling on ebay
maybe yeah and porn did really well back
in the day on ebay
true check this though this is the
strangest part in 2014 a father and son
were arrested on charges of storing
stolen property
at the residence but it is unknown that
the goods there now
are related to that matter yes and
that's 2014 so 60 years later
if that's the same stolen [ __ ] it's
still [ __ ] there so i'm like
do you get the stone [ __ ] that comes
with the house like it doesn't come with
the house
i would buy the house if it came with
all this [ __ ]
so it's like a treasure hunt yeah i'm
like what's in here it could be a lot of
cool [ __ ] it's a project
because it's like you already get your
300 000 worth with the house right yeah
and then on top of that you get all
these extra things that might be worth
roaches and dollars or a hundred
thousand dollars or a million it's like
the storage containers
civil war artifacts and [ __ ] yeah that's
worth a lot of money
watch it's just [ __ ] packaging
equipment so it's just like cardboard
box not the way that looks
from peanuts that's all it is styrofoam
peanuts on styrofoam yeah but they got
porn dvds though
true how are you gonna play them to
watch them joe they're collecting
there's probably a dvd player
in that [ __ ] pocket okay all right an
old tv too not a flat screen
that's 300 000. that's humongous nice i
mean there's potential here i mean i
think you could you could dig up like
you can make a fountain look at the car
but there's like a massive basement
underneath right
probably i don't know it looks like it
all right so here's the i wish this was
bigger you know what's funny it didn't
shock me because when i was looking for
places to just like ran and buy
um a lot of people just post [ __ ] like
this that's horrible
yeah they just [ __ ] post and they'll
be like yeah two-bedroom for rent
and it's like they just walk into
somebody that's already living and they
just take pictures and they post it on
zero
at least photoshop it like you could
clone stamp a lot of that great floor
over top of that table yeah you guys
should just look around zillow and see
the garbage that's on there and you're
like no wonder these [ __ ] can't sell
a house
true i love how there's stolen goods
there and the cops like probably went
there and they're like
ah [ __ ] it yeah close the case i don't
know i don't want to look through all
this [ __ ]
yeah here's the bathroom there's like
[ __ ] mcdonald's cup
it's like it's just it's just wrecked
they're not even minimalist
they're just recyclers yeah is that the
couple is that the new
trend the end that looks like step
brother's picture yes
do you see that yeah that looks like my
parents bedroom
really i'm not even kidding someone that
actually lives there or that's just like
a picture they have of some
something random like it's so random
everything there's a urinal bathroom
with a urinal yes
i want a urinal at my house check this
out toilet
yes damn so you could [ __ ] hold hands
while you take it you pictured the same
[ __ ] i did
it's like i need to brace myself ah
it honestly feels like one of those
monday park houses like in this area in
monterey park
like like chinese people like redo their
homes
nothing ever makes sense there's a
refrigerator next to a toilet like that
kind of [ __ ]
yeah it's just it's just made to house
16 people
yeah this makes more sense than the
french poop next to each other if
you think it used to be a wall like a
divider i don't know it seems like
you're sharing that
that uh the dispenser yeah wow oh
there's one right here oh maybe there
was there was a probably one
more class than that and then somebody
was like we don't need no stinking walls
this one says uh welcome to the man cave
up here
to the definitely men who live here i
would say so it's just a father and son
yeah but though they were arrested in
2014. so for whatever is there now
i don't know no one really has figured
it out what that [ __ ] baptismal
shower
do they did do they do everything in
pairs like they [ __ ] together as father
and son
they stole together as father and they
took showers with two [ __ ] heads
going and then like
the moment they wake up they just be
like
talking and inseparable i want that
relationship that's fun
and faith hey hey look at you joe being
all sentimental this is the relationship
you always wanted with your father
yeah but not my actual oh i got you i
wanna pretend
i want a lonely guy that's actually cool
as [ __ ]
that wanted a son figure and then we can
do this
okay i got you yeah it's like step
brothers fathers there you go step
fathers yeah that's a cool i do have a
stepfather but he's not that cool
because he talks too much
damn and i like to talk a lot what is
your ideal stepfather figure then
he's a quiet person who sits there while
joe talks a lot
he agrees with everything that i say oh
and he's lonely i want to get lonely
that's pretty good
my stepdad is actually cool as [ __ ] but
he's just too goddamn old
hmm yeah and he has the energy but not
the body
yeah so you don't want to see wrinkle
dicks when you shout no no no wait you
want a good looking body too
no no no no no he he can't keep up with
me he's pretty strong for a [ __ ]
geezer he's got cancer diabetes and he
pulls all nighters he [ __ ] travels
the world
he just still thinks that he's 20
something trying to come up with new
business ideas
but he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] he got in
trouble with the uh
with the filipino drug lord trying to
try to smuggle
illegal tuna into into america and japan
didn't know that he was getting fooled
because he's a complete [ __ ] [ __ ] i
was just
excited legal tune on legal tuna just to
be clear yeah true yeah well he got
yeah he got in trouble with some illegal
fishermen and then like he's just
he's just super out there right and i'm
just like dude you're not a businessman
you worked for the u.s government all
your life you don't know [ __ ] about
business
and then he's like yeah but i want to
buy your mom a house and i'm like you're
85 years old dude like you guys are
gonna die soon just have fun
and he still has dreams you know i'm
just like that's cool that's admirable
yeah but it's this i'm painting a good
picture but to me i'm just like you're
[ __ ] dumb bro
is that baseball cards i think they're
pornos that is porno
you should have known this one oh girl's
going wow
girl's going well what happened to girls
going well exactly
yeah it's true well you do jerk off the
girl's gone why unless you what do you
do when girls gotten wild
you jerk off okay okay there we go yeah
but then that [ __ ] they're not
[ __ ]
right right you just jerk off to them
getting topless and bouncing up and down
yeah
the world was so innocent then i know i
would still to this day
it's a mental thing for me i know that
girl is not getting paid she just wants
a free shirt
she just wanted to show her titties
that's hot to me that's cool i like that
i like that too true i like your mindset
i never try to think about where they're
coming from i know i always do
i like that i'm like hmm did she consent
to this video being online
i know she was okay with it being filmed
but did she say it can go online
i don't think so i don't think it was
meant to be online yet though it was it
was just dvd no i'm telling my
other you guys remember the uh ads uh
the infomercials of girls gone wild of
course and then like they would run for
like an hour right
so i was dating this girl and then she
was telling me that her grandpa she came
home
and then he was just like flipping the
channel and he's like he saw girls gone
wild and he's all like can you see this
man this is crazy how they're showing
this kind of stuff on tv these days
she goes to a room an hour later she
comes out he's still watching it and
he's still like judging it can't believe
this
i can't believe this
can you believe this [ __ ] i need to buy
this just to really see what's going on
1-800
but yeah real quick uh before we end the
video someone actually
i spent literally two hours drawing this
floor plan because i that extra so if
anyone wants to find out the bath
here you go so that's what i want to
know the original person that found this
and posted it and made it viral
uh was asking people if they could find
the bath the bathtub
and so now this person's actually drawn
the floor plan to figure it all out
and that's how that's how uh compelling
this house is and so yeah
it is amazing that's that baptism thing
yeah and that's the porn stash right
here right
oh my god it's testing the baptism yeah
as soon as you get out
are you tempted that's good
a little bit didn't work that's very
good before we got it flipped it's like
as you're going in you're like
one last time
[Applause]
[Laughter]
look at the best bud dad and son yes and
i leave you with and they look like
twins honestly
they're two brothers best buds and i'll
leave you with this whole
and why is this house in existence
i don't know yo if you leave it up to
guys they will [ __ ] some [ __ ] up like
that
wouldn't they guys decrease property
value i'm happy to hear all this you
guys you guys are making progress
because it's all true
oh we always knew but we always just
don't care
we don't care enough to change yeah we
just laugh about it because it's true
[Music]